it's not been easy for me it has not
been easy for me and you know I I
started off in Brooklyn my father gave
me a small loan of a million dollars
started from the bottom now we're here
started from the bottom now the whole
team here person started from the bottom
now we're here started from the bottom
now the whole team here person's back
when I didn't have a lot I'd head to the
old Navy barracks where I parked my
yacht how am I gonna make it I would ask
only had a work ethic and a suitcase
full of cash or started doing deals on
the scene most Everlasting companies the
world has ever seen it's the American
dream like they say some television work
is some eminent domain yes I don't need
anybody's here
I'm using my own money I'm not using the
lobbyists I'm not using donors I don't
care I'm really rich I'll share that
they say maybe you be out there on the
street
feeling worth less than a Wesleyan
degree but i'ma tell you how to be a G
doing lots of deals like nobody will
believe that bond get a million from
your pot what
is that not normal
started from the bottom now we're here
started from the bottom now the whole
team here